hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario maker with
Ross's stupid level okay so I took like
one second of a breather so that I'd be
able to collect my thoughts and move on
to this episode because I'll be god
damned if I'm gonna shred my voice
screaming at fertility oh god if that
wouldn't have done it for 30 goddamn
minutes an episode no way in hell am i
doing that maybe I should do that maybe
I should take a positivity again
sunshine rainbows blown out of my
nipples [ __ ] this in the anus to your
bag of dicks I don't have enough insults
to come up with us for this [ __ ]
this is a pile of dicks steaming from a
fresh pile of poopie one chicas early
morning poops that I have to deal with
every morning I mean not that I don't
love her not that I don't love chica
she's a great dog I love her to death
but you know dogs are a big
responsibility that's what your mommy
always tells you when you're a kid Oh
mommy I want a puppy
ooh no it's a big responsibility you're
gonna clean up its poop they don't tell
you about the poop big dog means big
poops poop factory nuts yes I know this
is gross I don't care I'm talking about
it this is reality this is a life I have
to live this is the things I have to
deal with pooping them when she poops
inside cuz she's not perfectly out
broken you know she's kind of
housebroken
oh you praise her when she poops outside
to give her a treat oh you can't score
too much when she goes inside yeah
stupid oh come on with this get out of
my way no [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] you
piece of ass so stupid [ __ ] you
goddamnit no [ __ ] you that was perfectly
uh oh oh god damn it just go oh my god
alright [ __ ] it I'm going not stop it
I'm not gonna stop I can't stop okay
I can't it's not okay that it's doing
this to me it's not okay
that I have to do this I don't do well
with raids games
I don't okay I don't I don't do well I
get angry really easily yeah haha it's
fun for you guys it's not fun for I
don't even want yell anymore I know I'm
shredding my voice yeah whatever it's
okay I'm gonna talk in a calm [ __ ] you
and your random god damn it [ __ ] you is
it so hard oh [ __ ] oh feed my nipples
[ __ ] you I did that on purpose jumping
into the love of Jesus it was [ __ ]
eating up a million years of time just
I'm not not happy right now if that
wasn't obvious people couldn't tell I'm
not not will you call happy not a happy
camper and now you know my normal why I
did exactly what you asked him you know
at this point I'm not even surprising
your [ __ ] now with that we got past
the part that I've already gotten past a
million times without any problems now
we can carry on to the rest of
stupid-ass level you just gotta go for
it you gotta go for it
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
and your oh my god [ __ ] you god damn
it's so stupid I swear I hit the jump
button I am okay I am happy I am
thinking of the most beautiful butterfly
right now the beautiful butterflies
flapping its beautiful wings down a
beautiful flower filled and filled with
beautiful people beautiful people and
beautiful puppies as far as the eye can
see they're all dancing and humping it's
so happy but totally platonic not in a
weird way not the people in the animals
the animals were humping other animals
and the people are humping other people
I want to be very clear about that it's
not weird anything but the butterfly the
butterflies there yeah the butterflies
is the whole reason I was talking about
this [ __ ] scenario just just just
just just just ha [ __ ] the humping
animals and the people are humping the
animals that's actually what's happening
and the butterflies like a God watching
over them and just watching his
creatures that are all humping each
other and they're not happy about it I
mean you know it's all it's all totally
platonic and everything but they're all
just humping away not in a sexual way
you know it's not in a sexual way at all
but you know and then all of a sudden a
dark storm rolls over and it's just
Ross's face in the clouds stupid grin in
his three-prong laughs you know what I'm
talking about
[ __ ] whatever God he's just up in the
clouds like a Monty Python version of
God you know I just wanted to parent
through the cloud and talking his
stupid-ass voice and you know you go you
look up and Ross and you're just like
Ross why why have you forsaken us and
then every time Ross looks down at you
and then he pays hate his face goes back
behind the clouds and then all you see
is just his butt cheeks spread over you
and he's just shits on your head that's
what happens and that's my happy place
apparently I forgot that I was talking
about my happy place with the butterfly
and the butterfly was God I think I
meant why did that time he'd take out
more coins that's what I want to know
why why do things change
why why does life have to change work in
what did i do differently going
backwards why I'm also playing I will
admit I'm also playing on Ryan's
controller and some of the some of the
buttons are gobbed up a bit cuz Brian
does nothing but masturbate every single
day of his life he never stops it's like
a joke he just constantly every single
hour of every single day is Ryan jacking
off so I can only imagine like his dirty
crotch hands touching all over this
stupid controller that he lent me and he
probably laughing in his room right now
while he's jacking off of course cuz he
does that 24/7
literally anytime he's not on camera
he's literally just just jacking off
what the [ __ ] was that what I want to
break it I want to break it but it's not
mine it's it's Ryan's just field
controller it's Ryan's just just
masturbation controller I know it's that
I know it is I know I know this is I
can't break it
cuz that would be mean he lent it to me
he lent it to me so I can't break it
usually if it's something in my own I
break it I feel fine I'll break
I break it I buy it I break it I buy it
but it's not mine so I can't if I crack
this open it's gonna be a horrible mess
for everyone involved no one wants to
see that well is it my happy place yeah
okay so riot Brian Ross is now the God
in the clouds why what why why he's [ __ ]
Ross is on Mount Olympus [ __ ] [ __ ]
limpets do it I [ __ ] do it [ __ ] [ __ ]
lympus that's [ __ ] what I said you
heard me god damn it
just and there's the humans are the
animals but they died a long time ago
cuz they were waiting for my boring
story to finish and so now it's just
Ross and he's an [ __ ] hate him
I wish bad things would happen to him
I wish good things would happen to him
he's a lovely person he's good guy good
friend nice guy wouldn't wish a bad
thing on him in my life I'm just gonna
kill I'm gonna kill bozer that's all I
care about
never mind
oh I can't do it I can't do it I can't
do this laughs I can't do this goddamn
level I can't do this goddamn level I
can't do this goddamn level I can't do
this goddamn level I can't do this
goddamn I don't handle I'm okay
okay I don't want to talk about my happy
place anymore my happy place got really
weird
Ross [ __ ] on everyone dead animals
dead from too much humping it's not a
good place not a happy place anymore my
happy place got really really disturbed
so I'm gonna make a new happy place it's
in the middle of a desert
there's no life anywhere because nothing
to hump then and frankly it's it's
rather ugly it's not even like a
beautiful oh nice desert is just ugly
ass ugly everywhere as far as the eye
can see and yeah it's it's just non-stop
ugliness like forever and ever so it I
mean that's cool and all if that's like
your thing I mean it's not my thing but
you know this is my happy place so I
gotta make it my thing so I started out
as like minecraft I just you know I look
for cactuses and you know I look for
gillum's I start making sand in a glass
cuz you know I want to build a nice
house but then I remember it's not
minecraft and I'm gonna die in the
desert alone and Ross is still there
[ __ ] on me and laughing um Ross um
Ross O'Donovan or Mia good now Oh Ross
Oh Donovan that's what he sounds like in
case you didn't Frick oh god damn you to
hell
I just all
I'm done thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next starting gun necessary like the
pixel